wie es das größte stürmen
das ist richtig
rostock/berlin sozialrecht und
philosophie erwartet
seit 2004 haben
hier
sein serbischer ist immer sehr sehr
witzig
er ist die diskussionen
unbezahlte vielen dank für den einladung
ich habe ganz lange überlegt nicht
diesen vortrag ich habe gestalten sollte
dann bin ich dachte außergewöhnliches
gestoßen ich habe nämlich vorgenommen
wenn ich mache diesen vortrag auf einer
tagung zur digitalität ohne digitale
unterstützung wäre damit sozusagen die
auf meine haut und dann kommt dann kommt
julian nida-rümelin macht den hörsaal
genetischen wandelhalle und schreibt
auch noch mit freibad und jetzt ist
natürlich alles was ich vorbereitet
haben nur ein abklatsch
also brauchen doch brauchen sie
verzichten ist jetzt nichts besonderes
mehr
meine idee war
den verzicht auf powerpoint zu
legitimieren und damit gleichzeitig das
tagungsthema zu erhellen
und es gibt prinzipiell so zwei
möglichkeiten wie man den verzicht
erklären kann
erster legitimation schiene ist
nazistisch die zweite ist ästhetisch die
nazistische legitimation des verzichts
auf powerpoint hat jobs herr der gerne
auch schon erwähnt wurde vorgestellt ist
nämlich gefragt worden
kassel benutzen sie eigentlich nie
behauptet und dann hat er gesagt jetzt
hier werner ziehen konnten zurück
norbert meister 1 so das war einigen und
aber die man ich lese nicht zu einseitig
versuchen das mal
ästhetisch zu gründen und zwar dann habe
ich mich daran erinnert dass es die
ästhetische theorie von wolfgang welsch
gibt ich weiß gar nicht ob die noch
aktuelle diskutiert wird die gestalter
äußerst wahrscheinlich
und da gibt es eigene gefahr nämlich
dass tätig und an ästhetik und stc ist
die thematisierung von währungen aller
art und an ästhetik ist an sieben teilen
die thematisierung des ausbleibens der
verhinderung oder der möglichkeit von
wahrnehmung durchaus anschlussfähig an
den medizinischen sinne nicht als
reichstes es ist die wahrnehmung
die anästhesistin raubt ihnen die
wahrnehmung und das ist unsere person zu
verstehen die das bei michael diese
können nach zunächst er hatte 2007 dazu
normalen netzen gesagt wir kennen die er
dazu und von den jeweiligen leitmedien
betreuungs oder und wir sehen und zu
sagen nicht die seiten strenge der
ebenfalls zur verfügung stehenden
mädchen die ebenfalls dazu beitragen
dass informationen übertragen
kommunikationskanäle haben usw
und wenn man das aus dieser perspektive
betrachtet ästhetik und ärzteschaft ihr
gesagt dass eine kleine ästhetische
lehrstellen die arbeit rechtzeitig etwas
vielleicht eine signatur der kultur der
die digitalität ist denn vor 40 jahren
war ein vortrag ohne powerpoint einfach
ein vorteil
heute ist aber so
powerpoint zumindest sprachlich gemacht
auch so markiert da kriegt man im radio
das brennende sektion dabei
weil das sozusagen andauerten und wieder
normal aussieht das heißt man kann
zumindest sprachlich nicht aus dieser
neuen ästhetischen erfahrung und ich
weiß nicht wohin das neue buch von made
in germany kennt und man weiß ich dass
er das camp das heißt social foto und
garish einkehrt strategie vieler leute
die sich die tops kennt also die sagen
dann jetzt möchte ich mal zwei wochen
das smartphone an die seite legen und
nicht mehr zurück ins tessin posten
sondern das wahre leben kann
funktion und das kann man hinfällt sich
kritisieren also dahinter steht die
falsche vorstellung als digital nur
diskurs das ist auf der einen seite das
echte leben gibt das ist ein nach oben
und der anderen seite geschafft die
scheinwelt des internets man kann es
kritisieren weil da hier keine falsche
vorstellung von einer unverstellten
bewegen und mit der natur steht als
literatur den weiß kann man dagegen den
kunden ankommen frauen oder sagen
jetzt wird diese vorstellung dass er so
eine form geben und ergänzen sagt dann
okay selbst wenn jetzt jemand sein
smartphone menschen die ganz bewusst und
seine ersten nicht fotografieren
dann erlebte dieses ersten leben nicht
beim essen sondern als nicht
dokumentiert werden in der schweiz
sozusagen die uns durch die kultur der
digitalität und wenn man dann strich
unser ziel kann man sagen könnte man das
beschreiben nennen
luciano flow medi und forschen
wir sind inzwischen im on ralf der
infosphere und die trennung zwischen
auflage von lynas bestenfalls
realistisch das könnte man eben der
effekt wer jetzt noch größer gewesen ob
er jetzt vom 3
der vorstand jetzt kommt der hauptteil
seiner einleitung hauptteil der vortrag
klingt ja
paradigmen im titel und gute ideen die
ich verfolge ich aber jetzt in den 30ern
nicht zu ende erzählen kann ist dass es
häufig von paradigmen die rede ist von
krise die rede ist von paradigma
wechseln die rede ist von revolution
bildungs revolution die rede ist und
dass wenn man glück hat noch den fuß
gesetzt zu dem eigentlichen ursprung
dieser begriffe der liegt nämlich in der
wissenschaftstheorie bei thomas cook in
dem buch das kreuz sei meistens endet es
dann mal gesagt man kann schon sagen
dass sie über umgesetzt und mein leben
mal zu gucken wie weit kommt man wenn
man diese begriffe von die tatsächlich
in den ursprünglichen setting aus der
wissenschaftstheorie anwendet um den
bildungs diskurs zu beschreiben und ich
bin jetzt also pro skizzieren was ein
paradigma oder paradies
das direkt ausgesprochen wird also wie
immer seit paradigma ist und damit
sozusagen gegen kürzungen diskurs zu
schlagen allerdings sind bei kuhn in der
wissenschaftstheorie an dem kriterium
die gebäude die das handeln von
wissenschaftlern mit wissenschaftlern
ein also ein paradigma sagt ihnen welche
fragen sie legitimerweise an die natur
stellen welche antworten als akzeptabler
antworten gelten welche methoden
verwenden und so was wie das ist also
unter logisches wagen neben methodischen
fragen werden vom paradigma beantwortet
und sie können sich leicht vorstellen
wenn sie ihn anhänger des bio
zentrischen ende sind dann sehen sie in
der natur andere dinge und sie berechnen
daneben waren anders als jemand der zum
beispiel in indien zentrischen welt
unterwegs ist chemiker die im paradigma
das feuer stoff für die es um die natur
beschreiben und überall wo es brennt den
first floor ist so nennt weichen sie ihn
beschreiben
erleben die natur anders als jemand der
ändern sauerstoff chemie sozusagen groß
geworden ist ja also ist die
unterschiedliche sicht auf die welt
oder nehmen sie noch ein extremes
beispiel wahrscheinlich sind hier in der
dreier von ihnen zumindest implizite
vertreter des naturalismus naturalisten
sagen wenn du wissen willst was du was
in der welt wirklich gibt dann musst du
die naturwissenschaften und juni
naturwissenschaft fragen und eine
gegenposition wäre zum beispiel die der
rationalen theologie klammer hier ist ja
selbst ernannte unterdessen von teams
aus berlin übergewechselt ins lager der
rationalen theologen ovationen und
rational hat ihre note zum beispiel
sagen der schöpfungsgeschichte in einer
bestimmten interpretation ist eine
bessere erklärung des ursprungs der welt
als zb der urknall
da können sie ihn sehen uns als täter
unterschiedlicher parallelen
die sehen die welt in unterschiedlicher
weise und handeln da unterschiedlicher
weise das interessante ist an dem
paradigma dass es in sich
strukturkonservativen ist also paradis
nicht darauf ausgelegt wirklich
innovativen zu sein sondern die sind
eher darauf ausgelegt ihre strukturen zu
bewahren und ein großteil der arbeit
der phase die kuh normal der
wissenschaft nennt besteht die lösung
von rechts die mit dem dramatiker
sozusagen auftauchen welche befinden
neuer trend
die höhe sind von rätseln grund in der
anpassung des paradigmas auf die
wirklichkeit also wenn irgendwas von dem
paradigma vorher gesagt wird was sich
dann in der welt so nicht einstellt also
eine voraussage die einstellung können
zumal wenn man jetzt so nadine kaß
juristisch nach kupfer denkt okay wenn
deine theorie vorhersagt aber in der
natur beobachten nicht gehen dann musst
du deine theorie im tennis aufgeben das
passiert aber gerade nicht sondern die
strukturen konservativen paradigmen
arbeiten wir daran das paradigma
sozusagen am leben zu halten diesen
irgendwie dient also da werden dann
angesichts solcher differenzen zwischen
theorie und die welt zum beispiel
zusammen haben gemacht oder es wird
gesagt also eigentlich müsste der planet
jetzt da sein aber gibt es dann das
liegt aber nicht daran dass unsere
theorie seite sondern wahrscheinlich
gibt es noch einen planeten entdeckt
haben dann könnte das nicht erklären
also was versucht so lange den wirklich
an dem paradies zu halten und es kommt
dann aber wäre es wenn die buchung einer
theorie zu groß werden oder wenn die
komplexität eines paradigmas nicht
proportional sondern erklärenden kraft
steigt zu einer phase den endkunden die
phase der krise davon haben wir ja
gerade im ersten vortrag auch schon
gehört und in dieser phase der krise
seien sehr deutlich
diese diskrepanz zwischen theorie und
welt oder paramount welt und wenn sie
ihn mit albanischer literarische
verklärung dieser phase der krise suchen
dann können sie in nachdrucken
weinbrecht leben des galilei
da gibt es diese szene galilei sagt ich
jetzt erstmal auf ich habe ein neues
feld für euch und die müsste nur durch
ein fernrohr schauen und einzusehen dass
euer weltbild als und beim recht ist es
dann so dass die kirche sich weigert die
wollen hier ein formales punkt sie
wollen über wales das nachschlagen als
durch dieses herrn zu schauen
das heißt das sie haben sozusagen diese
strukturkonservative tendenz paradigma
fest sein
also fahren die instruktoren und sehr
aktive gebildet an denen man auch
festhält wenn sich die welt nicht mehr
so verhält wie sie sich eigentlich
verhalten sollte
jetzt hofft man nun dass die kooperation
zwischen paradigmen und dem bildungs und
das ist glaube ich der begriff des
mediums ok gelegt was ist ein mieser
wenn wir jetzt die nicht sagen
vielleicht sagen
und dabei bin mir sicher die jetzt hier
auf meinen befehl hin dass weiß nicht
wie krank ist
gib mir sehe als definition von medium
natürlich die übersinnlichen definition
also medium ist siri die verbindung
zwischen unserer welt in einer
übernatürlichen geld wenn sie mich
fragen würde was ist der konsens begriff
von medium dann würden sie sowas
erhalten die das was leider ihr schon
weit verbreitet ist nämlich so ein
werkzeug hilfsmittel beschluss des
videos wo medien zu sagen unterstützer
sind für
gerichtsprozesse und mit diesen medien
begriff kommen sie mich besonders verein
der medien durch den sie bräuchten wäre
ein weiterer posten der in den linken
das medien prägende formen sind für
gesellschaft kultur ästhetik lernen und
wissen und bildung und da ganze reihe
von kandidaten die sie nehmen können
also ich nenne man sie können unseren
weiten medienberichten diese phänomene
zurück in auf herold.at aufmarsch an sie
können das machen die ihren rücken kann
das machen wir michael giese
sie können das machen gemeinsam quote
also damit schnitt das sind also alles
kandidaten offen stehen wenn sie diesen
beiden medium mit
und wenn sie dann medien als paradigmen
verstehen die ebenfalls einen rahmen
setzen um zum beispiel kultur und
gesellschaft dann können sie feststellen
dass sozusagen die in ihrem
kulturgeschichtlich sagen die phasen
unterschiedlicher medialer gegeben macht
das jetzt wirklich im schnelldurchgang
erstes großes mediales paradigma ist
primär über die themen also eine
gesellschaft in der sie nur die
möglichkeit zur verfügung haben und es
ist auch völlig geschafft
das ist sozusagen mediale paradigmen und
immer auswirkungen darauf haben was wir
unter lernen wissen und bildung
verstehen also bei der möglichkeit dass
das unmittelbar einsichtig wenn sie in
einer gesellschaft leben in der steam
endlichkeit müssen sie alles aus dem
wissen im kopf haben sie können ja nicht
auslagern ins neue oder in ein anderes
medium und das hat auswirkungen darauf
wie sie wissen erwerben und wie sie
wissen weitergegeben
also sie müssen zum schluss tricks
greifen wie nemo technischen hilfen also
rhythmisierung ein strukturen sind dinge
die ihnen helfen dinge in den kopf zu
bekommen und sich auch dabei helfen das
weiterzugeben
es gibt ja von vorläufig diese
untersuchungen die zeigen dass die
narrativen strukturen beim er massiv auf
die ohren sich gründen also selbst in
die verästelungen des erzählens hat es
das medium das als leitmedium aus dann
ist weiter vorgesehen gemacht dass er
schnell die erfindung der schrift
das skript topographie und jetzt haben
sie mensch als geschichtlich das erste
mal folgende frage zu entscheiden was
von leben das ich bislang im kopf habe
kann ich jetzt legitimer weise in das
neue medium der handschrift auslage
das ist eine frage die muss intelligent
entschieden werden kann und es gab
damals schon zur zeit der erfindung der
schrift die urszene der medienkritik bei
platon und fein raus und dem somit es
sagt wenn wir die schrift nutzen und die
dinge nicht mehr im kopf haben werden
geradezu dunkel weise weil wir jetzt
eben die sache nicht mehr im kopf haben
sondern auslagern das kann nur schlecht
sein
und wenn sie jetzt mal so zu sagen die
die den maßstab verändern und so ein
bisschen raussuchen bitte stellen sie
fest
diese frage was kann ich nicht immer
weise ins neue medium auslassen dann
stellt sich heute also heute stellen wir
die frage was muss sich noch bis in
letzte google aber das kann ich aus
lagern
in die algorithmen von google was ich
vorher vielleicht noch selbst wissen
und das ist sozusagen das zweite mal
dass ich jetzt diese frage stellt ist
nicht neu die gab es auch schon beim
übergang von
die cs kryptographie skript oder vier
hat auch dazu geführt dass ich überhaupt
so etwas entwickeln konnte wie
abstraktes denken und definition
versuchen sie mal ein abstraktes denken
definition verschachtelte erzählung im
video der rhein wirklichkeit abzubilden
das funktioniert nicht dazu auch
ungeschickt wenn sie das nochmal
nachlesen wollen empfehle ich den
klassiker von walter oder den täter und
mittäter kriegen sie das alles viel
schöner präsentiert sich das dahin der
nächste schritt dann wird er im 15
jahrhundert erfindung des buchdrucks und
damit ist jetzt zum beispiel verbunden
dass sie das wissen in die fläche
kriegen das war mit der handschrift
sowas wie die ausbildung eines
nationalen bewusstseins zum beispiel des
bunten an die möglichkeit zu sagen ob
der schrift sache nämlich in die fläche
zu bringen und es gibt ein neues buch
von immobilien die gitarre verwenden
darin schlägt er interessantes
gedankenexperiment vor was ein bisschen
zeigt wie auch unsere vorstellung vom
ist nun die strukturierung
von dem medialen paradigma menowin sein
stellen wir uns vor die gesellschaft und
kultur hätte sich nicht auf der
grundlage der bistums entwickeln der
buchdruck hat bestimmte technische
grundlage zum beispiel war wurden die
bergs erfindung besonders guten schwarz
auf weiß schwarze beweglichen lettern
auf weißem grund die prägen bis heute
unsere vorstellung von wissen also wir
sagen heute auch noch das möchte ich mal
schwarz auf weiß haben wenn wir das
limit ist und damit referieren wir
eigentlich auch die zugegeben
technischen eigenschaften der
lokalpresse
und was wäre denn gewesen wenn wir 500
600 jahren nicht sozialisiert worden
wären mit diesem schwarz-weiß paradigma
sondern
in der kette eine maschine von mit der
man farbige grafiken hätte verbreiten
können wo aus der politik gestaltet
die semantische dem dimension hatte sich
die hinter sich die gesellschaft
wenn dir so sozialisiert worden ich
glaube zum beispiel dass das was jetzt
im netz stark verbreitet wird so ist
kein schnelles ja das ist ein bisschen
die kultur der digitalität der
oberschichten bisher in den raum zurück
indem man wissen
er präsentiert das kätzchen sind gleich
zu sagen okay jetzt haben die qualität
das könnte für jeden der typographie und
wir können die digitalität und die ist
ja gerade stand erläutert worden in dem
drei aspekten rationalität
gemeinschaftlichkeit algorithmus i tät
ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz ein
aktuelles phänomen ins spiel bringen was
auch erklären kann nimmt das risiko wie
der von ihnen kennt das wiso video nicht
sie können diskriminierungsfreier
aufzeigen das sind also wahrscheinlich
versuchen neben den letzten vier wochen
im entfernten ausland verbracht haben
also ich kann das kann ich jetzt weil
ich eine frau bin ich noch mal zeigen
aber ein riesiger medium immer nur ich
glaube ich die steirischen kategorien
noch mal sehr schön sie in der theorie
so ist quasi die negation der gatekeeper
kunst ja sowieso ist nicht mehr abhängig
davon dass sie
dann redakteur seinen plan und das
irgendwo sendezeit in irgendeinem den
fernseher streamen bekommen sondern es
reicht im prinzip die webcam die kinder
jetzt klar dass es keine webcam ist und
auch kein kinderzimmer sondern dass die
produktionsmittel inter stehen aber im
reicht im prinzip ein link den er
produziert genannten verbreitet aus
allen geld jemand vorbei sozusagen seine
botschaft zu verbreiten dabei helfen
seine verloren hatte die die neuen
formen gemeinschaftlichkeit das vorher
glaubt 500.000 förderer oder abonnenten
bei youtube jetzt hat er glaube nein ich
und es helfen und natürlich neue formen
der algorithmen weil diese spielen
sozusagen in spezifischer weise die
times darum machen dass sie sozusagen
verfügbar
über dieses system von von links und das
heißt bei bedienung können sie
einerseits integration sozusagen in der
kultur sehen und andererseits noch was
viel interessanteres was sozusagen auch
wieso von der politik unterscheidet
nicht negieren auch das prinzip der
kooperation und konsultation weiter dass
sich mitglieder einer bestehenden gruppe
zum
politiker die neuen mitglieder selbst
wählen das ist cool rotation und auch
das von der krise war das überhaupt
nicht welche gemeinschaft der politiker
ist ein geben der ein notiert also auf
einer seite die gegen klima und
andererseits das prinzip der korruption
jetzt haben sie viele dass das wiso
video gesehen aus meiner sicht liegt
selber einwilligung was noch viel
stärker zeigt warum risiko tournee ist
gehört und zwar ist das ein milieu das
es gab danach sind sich youtube
die sitzen dann schließt das einfach
noch nicht gesehen aber dann kam lange
nichts und dann habe ich beim lesen auf
dem kanal kommt dann gibt es ein video
und ich glaube es sind auch schon
zweiten millionen klicks er macht der
folgenden zeit freuen unter dem namen
nichts zur sache tut und versuchen
möglichst leise chipstüten und
getränkedosen zu öffnen also dann läuft
jemand dezibel mindern
ja und misst wie lautet ihre chips im
norden sind
wenn du merken da habe ich mir gedacht
ich stelle mir vor wie in der
parteizentrale der cdu gut zusammen ist
und jetzt gespannt haben folgt was man
weiß nicht was man strenger wenn sich
jemand möglicherweise schiffstypen und
getränken das ist unsere größte schlag
ins gesicht
damit kann man sagen wenn man jetzt
diese paradigmatische perspektive
einnimmt dass man wieder versagt ihr
denken ist das glaube ich auch im
maßstab der betrachtung versucht jetzt
noch mal raus und guckt wo gab es schon
einmal ein wieso also gab es schon mal
eine einzelne person die mit hilfe neuer
medien neuer medien
das etablierte system in seine single
gemacht und antwort natürlich
sechzehnten jahrhundert resolution die
einzelnen das können sie nach
das können sie nachlesen bei tom ständig
in writing for social media die förster
und jetzt damit dass geschrieben
deshalb fliegen und bei stephan wende
von der universität augsburg mit diesem
vergleich auch zieht also derzeit die
einzige person die nicht besonders auch
in den ideen hat also hatte das im
jahrhundert vorher hatten ähnliche ideen
der hatte nur das pech dass er seine
ideen auf dem durch das paradigma der
kryptographie verbreiten wollte das hat
nicht geklappt hat jetzt verbrannt hat
den gut und kann seine ideen verbreiten
zwar und das arbeitet ähnlich selten
raus durch ein system das wir heute als
final zeichnen können also und ideen als
einzelner suchen gibt eine toga seien
konkret der druck da und stellt es man
immer wenn der martin vorbei kommt dann
reißen wir die leute am fleth aus der
hand das erzähle ich doch noch mal
meinen kollegen der anderen stadt
betreibt das ist sozusagen eine von
fried ja dann werden
dann werden diese
breite und jeder kauf ist sozusagen eine
form des dreiecks und ist historisch
verbürgt dass auch personen die nicht
sehen konnten
luther so fertig gekauft haben und das
ist ja im prinzip die höchst mögliche
form des lyc und mich wenn ich was kauft
oder sich gar nicht verstehen was sich
nicht selber lesen kann aber um ist
sozusagen ein dortmund ausdrücken möchte
durch einfach den kauf dieses dieses
auflehnt und jetzt kommen sie sich die
situation an der katholischen kirche am
liebsten hätten die natürlich gar nicht
regeln aber ab einer gewissen verbreiten
müssen sie reagieren dann können sie ja
wenn wir nämlich reagieren dann erkennen
sie die relevanz essen worauf sie
reagieren und es ist gleichzeitig klar
jemand nicht so populär seien in die
kritik und bei dem sogar das bis dahin
ähnlich ist am liebsten endlich
etabliert dass solche krise
totgeschwiegen aber bei einer bestimmten
clique zahl kann man ihn nicht bei den
mumien und dann sind sie sozusagen in
einer lose lose situation wenn finnland
oder ein video veröffentlicht hätte wäre
das wahrscheinlich noch die größere
katastrophe gewesen als jetzt
seit die spd es als antwort kann also so
können sie mit dieser pragmatischen
perspektive
die parallelen zum beispiel zwischen den
den mechanismen die bei nutzer jetzt
möchte ich kurz auf diese phase der
krise liegen die beiden charakteristisch
für den übergang zwischen zwei parallel
dazu muss man erst mal sagen
die schule ist ein teil der sozialen und
theologie gehören ja gleich noch was
über unterliegen und soziale ökologie
meint einfach kann man kann das
kompliziert ausdrücken kann sagen also
neben den stein und die schule dann ist
ersteigen die philosophie sagen würden
maximal modell robust also auch wenn es
keine menschen gebe die an den nächten
im eigenschaften zugeschrieben gäbe es
denn steigen
in der gleichen weise ist aber die
schule nicht maximal denn sie hängt ihre
existenz von menschen auch die daran
glauben und bei der sozial anthologien
kann man sich berufen zum beispiel der
gesagt hat was den menschen vom tier
unterscheidet ist dass menschen personen
oder dinge eigenschaften
definitionen zu beschreiben können die
diese personen oder dinge nicht nur
aufgrund gemacht physischen
eigenschaften innerhalb das klingt jetzt
kompliziert ist aber ganz einfach
nämlich das wollte nicht eine andere das
rotlicht der ampel hinter ziemlich
fühlte staaten über die straße zu gehen
dennoch nein wahrscheinlich viele auch
nachts um drei vor der roten ampel
stehen weil sie unserer gesellschaft der
als teil der sozialen und theologie als
ein zeichen natürlich davon stehen
bleiben so funktioniert
sozialanthropologie des c7 kontext als
immer diese und im straßenverkehr als
stoppsignal
oder ist es kein geld dabei diese
stimmen gedruckte papier zähle in
unserer gesellschaft als legitimes
zahlungsmittel oder bistro noch die
chance dieses bedrohte stimme papieren
in zahlen auf zählt im bildungssystem
als eintrittskarte für ein studium
und sie sehen das funktioniert nur weil
ja das ist der zweite punkt bei und ihr
alle kollektive internationalität
hinsichtlich dieser funktion ausbilden
also wenn wir die jugend leute daran
glauben dass ein
konzentriert funktionieren der
straßenverkehr gelten und geld weil
gerade daran glauben dass das geld das
hat man in jeder währungskrise und eine
schule ist nur eine schule weil wir
daran glauben dass die zertifikate was
fehlt also ich finde die drei der
sozialen ontologie und gebunden und
kollektive internationalität und jetzt
gibt es anzeichen der krise wo man sehen
kann dass es möglich ist dass die
kollektive intensität gegenüber der
schule brücke und damit sich jetzt drei
beispiele wo sie das sehen erstes
beispiel prüfungsformen großformate
stammen aus einer welt die sozusagen
jetzt
typografie paradis marke wenn sie heute
in der echten welt ein problem lösen
worden
machen sie ganz auf eine reise bestimmt
nicht werden sie haben ein problem
dann werden die wenigsten von ihnen
folgendes tun sind gegen mich in einen
raum in dem sie allein wenn sie keinen
empfang haben und wo sie gar bereichen
handschriftlich etwas auf papier
schreiben sie laut unter hier das ist
meine lösung so lösen sich keine
probleme in der echten welt das sind
dabei standardbedingungen ist abitur und
es geht weiter wir sollen in der wir
sollen in der echten welt sollen die
vier karren fahren andere kreativität
kritisches denken kommunikation und
kollaboration einen nicht militärischen
sinne und dann ist es dieses ansehen
dann stellen sie fest 2 und 4 k sind
unter abitur bedingungen form des
betrugs nämlich kommunikation und
kooperation oder kollaboration nicht
mehr lehrerinnen oder lehrer seine
schüler im dezember mit einem anderen
spricht und sagt moment dass es doch die
ausübung einer eines dieser hier kann
man sehen wie wir die welt und die
schule da nicht mehr aufeinander passen
ferner hat das 92 schon
klar herausgearbeitet hat nein das ist
ein mythos dass lernen sozusagen ein
solitäres eine solitäre veranstaltung
ist und das sozusagen die formen der
kooperation immer noch als zweiter und
damit man sich jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr
verdient er gesehen dass schule oder die
gesellschaft und bestimmte vorschriften
auseinanderfallen des datenschutz und
ich weiß dass man in deutschland wenn
man daten schon sagt immer gleich
angefeindet wird und beim urheberrecht
ähnlich und ich möchte ich ihnen meine
analogen zeigen von der ich glaube dass
sie ganz gut die situation im
datenschutz insbesondere für gesundheit
ist verdeutlicht und das gibt's nicht
orientiert sich daran dass 9 und lässig
vorgetragen als 80 des jahrhunderts
grundstücksrecht
und wer ein grundstück gekauft er wird
nicht nur das rechts an der fläche
sondern auch das recht unendlich weit in
die höhe und unendlich tief
das heißt jemand der unsere kaufte
konnte sicher sein darf da auch
niemandem im jahr überschritten und auch
nicht unterbunden dass irgend 200 ja
dann kam mitte des zwanzigsten
jahrhundert die verkehrsflugzeuge und
die freude über diese grundstücke und
weil sich das gros ist endlich da und
erstreckte war klar die verletzten die
grundstücksrecht das ging auch nach der
zeit bis sich zwei bauern beschwert
haben
deren hunger immer gegen die
scheunenwand geflogen sind wenn diese
flugzeuge umstritten und die abgesagt
und sagen meine mutter bei dem übrigens
nicht gut und ich möchte jetzt das hier
aufhören weil mein grundstück zufrieden
und ein gericht hat dann entschieden
dieses gesetz fast nicht mehr zur welt
dem müssen wir das ändern
die technik hat sich entwickelt und
dieses gesetz passt nicht mehr zu
wir brauchen ein schuss konsens in der
rechtssprechung und ich würde die
branche das kind das in der anschluss
auch hätten in der schule sondern das
müssen wir für jedes einzelne händen und
für jede einzelne ip adresse die über
ungerechte über jede spende über jedes
angedockt und über jede erstmal eine
holen und das ist einfach weltfremd
also es gibt doch so etwas wie die
kriminalisierung von alltagshandlungen
in social linie gerade auf dem
urheberrecht aber irgendwann davon mit
stahlplatten die durch durch endlich hat
man während einer timeline um 14.000 das
ist darauf der nächste punkt den ich
hinweisen will wo man diese diskrepanzen
sieht fällt unter den zweiten
palliative didaktik den begriff habe ich
mir mal zwei jahren ausgedacht und habe
dafür schon viel prügel bezogen
ganz kurz palliativen didaktik main ist
einerseits dass die schule ein
sternensystem ist dass man nur noch
rechts und palliativmedizinische
maßnahmen am leben erhalten kann also
die schule ist des typografischen
paradeplatz und dann mache ich sehe zum
beispiel diese big data förster leisten
einige sachen als form von palliativen
musste jemand nicht mehr den essays
korrigieren das macht der alten und der
lehrer seien eigentlich zu einer
künstlichen künstlichen intelligenz der
algorithmus die künstliche intelligenz
koordiniert und wenn es zweifel gibt
dass und dann kommt der dna hat
schließlich kürzlich in genf eine
dystopische um die zweite these hat von
kreativer didaktik dort an und die
bedeutung des lateinischen wortes paar
jahre das meint momenten und was sehen
den schulen häufig vorfinden ist
sozusagen die eine chance die
wiedergeburt des bieters muss also eine
didaktische
siebenmal der puristische prinzipien in
digitalen genannt also die haben als
reaktion und rückmeldungen die 3 r
statt der 4 also die haben den logitech
sie streiten was wein reaktionen sie
kriegen sofort eine rückmeldung das ist
genau auf tour und dann haben sie bei
den üblichen verdächtigen links rechts
oder links kam und so haben sie
tatsächlich den fall dass sie raus
digitales bling bling haben und ihnen
hockt grinsend das ist genau und das ist
in diensten für das sozusagen das
paradigma der alten schule
strukturkonservativ festzuhalten und dem
was sie hat ich glaube sie bekommen
einfach für beim pessimistische fazit
und das schließt an eine unerwartete was
sich in allen einen fehler von deren
sicht nie lernen und lernfähigkeit reist
und dort ein bisschen auch die
geschichte des lernens und
die medialen paradigmen beschrieben und
dort arbeitet er heraus dass mit der
erfindung der anstrich mit der
realisierung keinesfalls sofort
verbunden war dass man noch auf
handschrift sozusagen als lernmedien
setzte jahrhundertelang war die
handschrift nur dann unterstützung des
hilfsmittel für form ermöglicht
man hat beim lernen weiterhin auch das
gesetz was man aus dem paradigma der
moralität kann zeitschriften und
hilfsmittel so ein bisschen so wie sie
das heute aus der diskussion kennen
digitale hier sind nur unterstützende
ist für unsere etablierten und politik
und meinungsforschung ist es dass es bei
der digitalisierung ähnlich sein könnte
und jetzt ich habe die lebens und das
ist ja so das paradebeispiel dafür dass
er auf der einen seite galileo galilei
sind vertreter der bahn starten und auf
der anderen seite die kirche als die
dogmatische unvernünftig und es gibt
einen zweiten platz in der
wissenschaftstheorie neben kuchen
nämlich paul feyerabend suche ganz
beendet
und da gibt es wunderbare kapitel über
dem disput zwischen
unter den leon kalin das fazit ist aus
der perspektive der damaligen zeit hat
die kirche die rationale position für
uns ist was der perspektiven klar
galina der vernünftige damals war das
alles andere als klar
und die begründung ist relativ einfach
wissenschaftlich hat sich die kirche
nicht so verhalten wie eben recht das
skizziert hat die haben durch das
verkaufen
aber was sie gesehen haben waren keine
beweise die den sturz eines weltbildes
rechtfertigt punkt 1 und sie haben das
anerkannt als ein rechenmodell aber man
soll das rechenmodell nicht mit der
wirklichkeit verwechselt
das haben sie aber die ebene war gar
nicht die entscheidenden die
entscheidenden elemente sozial
gesellschaftlichen die kirche nicht sagt
aus einer verantwortung die position
heraus gesagt hat wenn wir jetzt den
galilei rechtliche implodiert und der
ganze laden also müssen wir das beste
also das ist jetzt die kurzform zu
können dass bei feierabend zudem
detailliert nachlesen
also was der damaligen zeit eine
vernünftige entscheidungen sozusagen
da nicht sofort auf galilei stute
aufzuspringen sondern auch sozialen
unter eindruck an paradigma am alten
kanal ihn fest so jetzt kommt die
aktuelle situation damit ich glaube dass
zurzeit wenn wir sich so die schulen
kennerblick angucken die einflussreich
ist also anwesen gewinnt natürlich
ausgenommen wenn die kritiken der
einfluss ist natürlich die arbeit
anwesend
damit finden sollten uns auf die themen
wie lernen und bleibt lernen oder
pädagogik vor technik oder digitalem
einigen jahren findet nunmehr oder
während medien sind unterstützende
werkzeug das ist anders glaube ich
gerichtet an die leute die mit ihrer
kollektiven internationalität das alte
system stützt
und dann gibt es nur logistische leute
dem zustand ihrer zimmer in bildungs
diskurs und das sind sie gar nichts von
heute
aber die haben wir vielleicht noch nicht
aus man kommt durch deren fernen
rotieren digitale verlor man sieht
vielleicht irgendwann aber das reicht
nicht um das system zu stürzen
also mit putin einig diese konservative
strukturkonservative schulpädagogik
momentan das einzig richtige aus der
heutigen sicht in 100 jahren wird man
dann den content der prüfung so
gestalten dass da einige größere gebiete
wie kommen die ähnliches verbieten zum
beispiel aber heute ist das gericht noch
wenn man im vergleich zu sagen die
richtigen sozialen verantwortungsvolle
strategien ja soll ich machen alles
richtig aber eben 100 jahre man sagen
kann alles falsch da müssen die wiederum
und mein schönster
in dieser dieser sache bräuchten
anschluss das ist was er braucht ist
eine vision eine riese für den
bildungssektor und er muss er muss
sozusagen bessere argumente haben als
ganze leben leben in kollektive
internationalität auszuheben und daran
sehen sie doch eigentlich will ich das
sie haben
schweden
vielleicht
daten und zahlen
gesellschaft eine sache glauben muss man
alles genau das ja von meiner seite
zusammen
vortrag vielleicht in ordnung konform
gehen und mit einem punkt nicht und
dieser leoni hässlichen cornelisen bin
ich nicht aus strukturkonservativen
bezeichnen kann
wenn ich wirklich aus dem beruf
bezeichnen dessen ausbildung sollen im
neuen rennen sehen soll er hingegen sind
diverse schränke sind intensität und das
sollen explizit das nicht macht und
erscheint mir durchaus eine rolle aber
sonst eher strukturelle richtige er
inhaltlich falsche strukturen richtige
antwort auf das problem zu sein
diese werden sich die als sehr amüsiert
bezeichnen ist ja auch sehr nachlässig
zu autorisieren
und ich glaube es ist notwendig in der
kritik da von epson wissen kommt china
weg zu gehen
und all dem humoristischen zwischenzeit
aus sie trotzdem durch die die
grundlagen der großen digitalen systemen
menschen mobilisiert werden
das von dem eher ruhig wenn ich da dass
die strukturellen blick passiert der
antwort die arbeit im wald richtung
gegen diese problematischer ist zu sehen
dass ein verein etwas beispiel sozusagen
werden wer behauptet kriegt er also ich
auch nicht so weit gehen zu sagen jeder
der diesen herbst oder gar nicht nutzt
ist deswegen zu verteufeln
es gibt bereiche in denen die durchaus
sinnvoll eingesetzt werden können hat
durch sagt man vom kapitalisierung in
fremdsprachen bereichen funktioniert
vielleicht über solche apps ich glaube
die kritik richtet sich eher dahin dass
eben gerade die hier kann nicht das sind
was im quadratischen system sozusagen
als richten sondern das mit dem
interimistischen tendenzen
jetzt die alte schule tatsächlich
gestützt wird und zwar weil die kinder
erwähnt haben ja sogar noch in einer
weise dass kinder niemals unterstützt
hätte denn dass kinder immer nachwuchs
ist genau in die karten spielen weil es
kinder selbst sagt es reicht nicht aus
einer liste von vier antwortoption einer
auszugehen sondern ist selbst was
schreiben ja also was kinder würde nicht
mal so schlecht ska und bestimmte für
bestimmte tendenzen es gibt daneben
bildungsbereichs sachen da habe ich
gesehen habe hier in caputh zur
aufklärung so also sein körper nicht nur
das ist ja sozusagen ein widerspruch in
sich freuen auf aus dieser perspektive
[Musik]
dann müssen
das gros dieser saison
doch letztendlich als neue handlung
[Musik]
fisch das im positiven bereich
wir haben ja also das sehr viel längere
antwort aber im prinzip ist die etwa der
sturz von und pädagogin vor technik auf
das primat der didaktik klappte so denke
ich auch und die kritik an trainer lob
von technik ist in der kurzform so
dieser satz das bestenfalls trivial also
pädagogen technik meint in der ersten
lesung hat technik muss den menschen
dienen und nicht der mensch der technik
das können sie aus technik
philosophischer sicht sozusagen schon
als definitionen von technik sehen
und jemand der sagt technik und dem
menschen dienen und nicht der mensch der
technik wieder auch öffentlich ein
definitorischen merkmalen von technik
und sagt so etwas wie europas aufseher
im kreis übrigens der grund also erfüllt
einer debatte nichts hinzufügen die
anderen staaten sind pädagogen vor
technik das ist einfach zu sagen technik
blind weil er suggeriert dass hier im
unterricht zu sagen ja später publik
machen müssen und uns dann zur jetzt in
digitalen medien die technik erstmals
ein
da wird aber ausgeblendet und das ist
eben der fall
bedienen können das natürlich die
schrift und das um ebenfalls form von
technik sind also ist nicht so dass es
an richtige frei unterrichtet haben
und jetzt kommen mit dem ipad kommt mit
dem reiten die technik in den unterricht
sondern technisch optimal da und
außerdem gibt es keine genommen wir
kommen da hab ich ja nur dann eine
antwort auf klafft die heimat patrick
schulz 65
die gesagt haben das ist nix mit einem
primat der taktik sondern müssen den
komplexen internet ergänzend ist
inzwischen bedingungen und entscheidungs
feldern unterrichten so wie es aussieht
wird noch nicht sagen
techniktrainer aber pädagogik von
technik ist ihr können zeigen die kultur
ist durch den technik sind und
bestenfalls trivial nächste ich am
anfang
[Musik]